hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the uh uh event that finished
yesterday the oslo esports cup it's a
wonderful game between eric henson and
young sister of duda and it is the final
round and now everyone thought that the
event would be a race between magnus and
pragyananda then uh when it
turned out that that will not be the
case uh liam leia was uh the one that
was supposed to win the tournament and
then in the end uh the tournament was
won by none other than yang shish of
duda so it will be uh of course the only
natural that i show a game of his and i
chose this game it's again from the
final round that was played yesterday
but if you guys have any other games
that you guys enjoyed by dudas i don't
think we've shown a lot of them uh from
the event uh do use hashtag suggestion
and i will of course consider your
suggestion uh so now it's a great game
duda goes for the berlin defense which
uh is uh well uh not all that exciting
but uh when i show it on this channel it
usually is exciting which means
something cool happened
and this is one such occasion so let's
see what happened eric has the white
pieces and he opens with e4 uh we have
e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop
to b5 area goes for the rue lopez
defense and we have knights uh knight to
f6 the berlin defense of the real opus
d3 and now bishop to c5 we have c3 and
now uh usually you just castle here and
there are of course many many uh games
in the database here but duda goes for
the somewhat rare d5
now uh especially in these open um
open variations of open uh
openings or open uh structures uh it is
uh not uh that uh uh
poisonous to open up the the position
right away because the positions are
well known and if it was a classical
game you probably would not play
something like this but this is rapid in
here dude i think all right eric let's
see how you how you handle this uh are
are you uh well versed in the uh all the
uh tricks and hidden secrets of the
berlin defense so here we have e
captures on the e5 eric accepts this
queen captures on d5 and now bishop the
c4 going after the queen but it's only
natural you are threatening bishop
captures an f2 check and then you're
just gonna win the pawn uh and the
bishop on b5 so here bishop moves back
with tempo the queen has to move queen
back to d6 not the d7 queen back to d6
and not knight b to d2 continuing
development even though uh many a player
would just go b for a for b5 as it's a
very hard to pass on an opportunity to
to start pushing that b4 pawn but okay
we have bishop to f5 do the continuous
development and now queen to e2 again uh
b4 does seem like the way to go here
queen to e2 is played uh we have castles
and now comes knight to g5 here knight
to the e4 is a known move but knight to
g5 uh it is as of move tended we have a
completely new game
and uh duda uh needs to make a move so
of course uh eric wants even more
control over the e4 square he's gonna
put a knight there put pressure on the
queen on the bishop on everything and
he's gonna try and take advantage of
this uh dude that still has the bishop
pair and it can be very very dangerous
so here we have queen to d7 so when the
queen and bishop uh
so the queen and bishop will not be
attacked we have knight d to e for now
attacking the bishop and the bishop back
all the way to e7 uh we have bush uh
knights to g3 now challenging the light
squad bishop as well and bishop to g6
and here eric starts pushing with h4 so
he decides to keep the king in the
center for the moment
and if he can get h5 in that's going to
be very good for him but uh
duda says my bishop is already attacking
the d3 square or rather the d3 pawn the
queen is helping out so let's play rook
a to d8 to bring a rook into the game
and prevent this uh well if you push the
pawn i'm just gonna capture on d3 so we
have knight five back to e4 now the
bishop can no longer capture on d3 and
here knight to a5 duda goes after the
bishop here uh and now uh what do you
play well probably best is to just
capture on f6 and push the pawn to h5
but it's still uh it's uh well your
position is worse and now uh you just
have to accept this and uh you know face
the face the reality but that's easier
said than done in chess for example
bishop captures h5 and now we give up
the d3 pawn everything gets traded off
captures captures captures and captures
now you can play king e2 or something
yeah you're down a pawn but you are
maybe maybe still playing the game
however here bishop the b3 was played
and now uh duda's position is uh well
completely winning uh but you have to
realize one very specific um
fact or even just truth about the
position in order to figure out what
this idea is so feel free to pause the
video and try to spot this idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh brilliancy and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is knight
captures on b3 connected with h6 so h6
move has to be played but we first
eliminate the bishop from b3 and then
our position will be
or rather our position is already
completely winning we just have to
remove that one move of counter play
that white has and that is pushing the
pawn to h5 and just to give you an
example if knight captures on b3 and
congratulations to everyone who figured
this out you could also play h6 right
away knight captures on b3 is more
precise followed by a6 now the thing is
after a capture on b3 uh if you capture
on d3 and that's kind of the thing that
we are threatening uh the problem is
queen captures rook captures and now
there's knight captures on f6 bishop
captures and h5 traps the bishop because
now the bishop is locked in by our own
rook
and well that's just sad we're going to
have to give up rook for a knight here
just uh to stay in the game but white
will be better after that so here do the
plate h6 and now there is not all that
much that you can play uh for example if
you go for rook captures on a7 which
seems like a great idea the knight to d5
maneuver is uh so deadly that white will
not be able to do anything about it the
knight is coming to f4 then you're going
to push f5 and these knights are just uh
terribly terribly placed for example if
castles were going to play f5 and not
after the knight moves knight f4 it's uh
i mean a disgusting position to to play
with white also the h4 pawn can always
be captured so it's just uh just
outright bad so instead after this h6
move we have h5 first challenging the
bishop bishop to h7 and now eric goes
for rook captures on a7 uh but
uh it still doesn't help aduda goes for
knight to d5 like in the position that
we've shown rook captures on b7 he grabs
another pawn and now knight to f4
attacking the white queen and the uh the
the the g2 pawn and if you play
something like queen to f1 to keep an
eye on the pawn we can just play knight
captures on d3 with check and of course
black a white position completely falls
apart so here uh duda uh eric plays
bishop captures on f4 we have e captures
on f4 and now again what do you play the
problem with moving the knight and where
are you moving the knight the only
square
available for the knight is the f1
square uh we just play rook after e8 and
look at this all of this stuff on the e
file f5 is coming there's just no
surviving this for example if you try
running away king to d2 we can play
bishop g5 not threatening um a move like
f3 opening up a discovery here if king
c2 it seems like white even succeeded in
running away to the queen side but we
can just play rook captures on e4 d
captures and the bishop captures an e4
with check where the uh of course the d
file is completely of limits you can't
go to b1 you the only square you have is
c1 and then again you go under the mask
of the bishop and the f3 will end the
game so you're going to have to capture
and then let's say queen to d1 and this
is now checkmate so that's out of the
question so after e captures on f4 duda
plays uh sorry eric plays d4 and now
offering the knight on g3 but at least
he won two pawns the a7 pawn and the b7
pawn so okay dude i place f characters
on g3 we have knight captures and g3 and
now queen to c6 attacking the rook and
the g2 pawn
we have queen to f3 offering a queen
trade while defending both the pawn and
the rook we have queen to a6 threatening
queen to a1 but also preventing the
white king from castling as you cover
the f1 square
so rook captures on c7 eric grabs
another pawn and now bishop to d6
there's just no
good way to uh to play this with white
anymore we have rook to c4 and now comes
queen to a1 with check queen to d1 we
have to block this uh or of course you
you don't have to block this you could
also play something like king to d2 but
then of course the b2 pawn is lost and
then everything just completely
deteriorates uh so instead after queen
to a1 queen to d1 and now rook after e8
with check we have to block with knight
to the e2 and here uh duda played queen
captures on b2 andy was in this position
animal 27 that eric hansen resigned in
the game
as there is nothing more uh to be done
here so really really a wonderful
display of how uh just uh you know uh
choosing to play a line that um
not a lot of people play uh here just
going for a straight up uh expansion in
the center with the d5 isn't considered
all that great but if you uh you know
just try playing it even against a very
strong opponent like eric in practice
it's not so easy to to handle now of
course uh you resign here after queen
captures on b2 because how are you uh
playing this i mean this uh everything
is hanging um
you can't really move
anything if you move the rook we're
gonna capture on c3 as the knight is
pinned uh if you
uh
it's hard to even imagine a move with
white let's say you try something like
castles uh of course you just lose the
knight here so the king and queen are
stuck here guarding the uh the knight on
e2 if you try something like rook h3
maybe with the idea of covering up with
rook to e3 it's still very very
insufficient for example rook captures
on e2 queen captures in the now queen to
c1 check forcing the queen back to d1
after queen d1 just rookie 8 check and
now finally after rook to e3 which was
the original idea behind the rook
maneuver we're gonna capture and after
pawn captures queen captures on e3 and
now whatever you play you're getting
checkmated queen e2 just bishop to g3
check the bishop pair is fully uh
absolutely fully operational here uh
king f1 queen to c1 check and that's it
queen to e1 queen captures an e1 will be
checkmate so of course eric saw this and
after queen captures on b2 he resigned
in the game and a very nice victory for
young sister of duda who uh
in his match against eric won two games
and the one ended in a draw so it was a
very very a very clean uh
match and just in case uh
i'm wrong i'm going to check this
sometimes i deceive you but that's not
on purpose yeah two of the games were
won by duda and the one ended in a draw
uh and that's it the fourth game was not
uh i wasn't even played uh so yeah
really good stuff by duda uh these are
the final standings as i know you guys
are always interested in this uh uh
from the chess24 twitter account uh so
first place young shisht of duda with 14
points liam le with 13 points in second
uh third and fourth place with 12 points
magnus carlsen and
shakti and mamadara with eleven jordan
fun forest with 10 anish geary with nine
and eric hansen eighth place with three
points so there you have it quite an
interesting event uh of course the the
faster the format the faster and crazier
the games and i think that's something
you guys
enjoy uh but of course there are a lot
more
uh rapid and blitz events nowadays than
there were let's say five years ago uh
so it's it's in fact a classical
tournament that that is rare nowadays uh
but yeah enjoy enjoy it uh while it
lasts who knows uh what the future will
uh will look like maybe we will only
have bullet and hyper bullet games or
maybe even just ultra bullet games or
maybe even uh who knows uh so uh once
again big congratulations to duda on
winning this uh this event if you guys
have any other game games that you
enjoyed from this event uh use hashtag
suggestion i will go over your
suggestions and hopefully uh cover them
uh so once again i really hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
robert arthur always poison hubba uh
michael mcconnell and nagarjuna ponogoti
and suresh for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day